everyone I'm kiskeya Buki I'm the
producer of the Nintendo switch game arm
today I'd like to introduce you all to
arms arms it's a fighting sports game
the uses extendable arms to battle it's
like boxing where you hit your opponent
with punches but it's also like shooting
where you aim and fire at distant
opponents to play arms you hold one joy
Khan in each hand in a thumbs up pose
the joy Khan senses your emotions so
when you punch your character also
punches when you twist your fist your
punch curves with this you can pursue a
distant enemy you move your character by
tilting the joy Khan and by combining
dashes and jump you can perform a
variety of actions because arms uses
physical controls anyone can pick it up
and play right away but we've made it so
that as you play more you'll uncover
high-level techniques and strategies now
I'd like to show you a battle between
two of our team members
promotion here are some of the
characters who appear in the game spring
man and ribbon girl it's a very fast and
active fighting game they're trading
punches back and forth you can garden
this game but they're practically
battling without guarding at all right
now oh dear spring man is on the roof oh
but here spring man with a special
attack Oh spring man 1 as you saw the
most appealing part of arms is battling
you can battle alone against the
computer and you can play splitscreen
against a friend as you just saw you can
also bring your Nintendo swish systems
together to battle and of course we're
preparing online battles as well the
extendable arm fight game arms were
released this spring thank you very much